hello everyone and welcome to the first
game of the first match of the finals of
the earth things masters it's levin
aaron versus taymor rajabov
and uh this is actually game four not
game one uh the first three games ended
in a draw but eleven was
kinda a little bit better in all three
games and now
this is the fourth one and it's it's a
very interesting game so let's just
check it out hope you guys enjoy it
eleven with the white pieces opens with
e4
and here we have e5 in game two uh rajab
went for the sicilian defense and
like we said that game ended in a draw
and here he's trying out e5
which usually means as we uh often say
uh
in this level of competition that it
will be a berlin defense so knight f3
knight to c6 and bishop to b5 the royal
opus is on the board and knight f6 the
berlin defense
uh we have castles here by 11 and now
knight captures an e4
the so-called rio gambit we have d4 and
now
knight to d6 attacking that bishop on b5
so just uh bishop captures and c6 with d
captures and d
captures on e5 so this has been played a
million times
and as usual when i say million i mean a
lot a lot of thousand times
so knights the f5 getting the knight out
of the way and now
a nice queen trade as you usually have
in a berlin defense so
h3 and now bishop to d7 at some point
black would want to play c5 bring the
bishop over to this diagonal
we have rook to d1 now pinning that
bishop and the king to c8
just getting the king out of the way and
here we have g4
it's a very aggressive approach it's not
a new move or anything uh it's been
played many times by many many strong
players like caruana grishchuk and maxim
varchelagrav
linear dominguez played it and so it's
not new to either of them uh we have
knight back to e7
and now knight the g5 going after that
f7 pawn
so bishop to e8 rajabo defends it and
now
f4 and here 11 created a bit of a
monster chain here on the king's side
and uh you have to deal with it at some
point uh either by
pushing h5 right away you want to attack
it or by
doing something else here rajabo goes
for c5 and
it's only been played once in a game
dominguez versus malcolm
in the affiliate world cup in 2015 uh
but we're going to get back to that
so making room for that light square
bishop in the future knights to c3
and now b6 defending the c5 pawn uh and
preparing king to b7 at some point so
you can bring the rook into the game
and here in the game that we mentioned
dominguez versus versus melcomian
uh from 2015 king to f2 was played but
here we have
f5 and it is only as of move 15 that we
have a completely new game so 11
really improving his that monster pawn
chain here on the king side
and rajab needs to deal with it and uh
there are a couple of ways of course you
can uh
try and undermine the pawn chain right
away when was like a
h5 but he goes knight to c6 first
attacks the e5 pawn uh trying to bait
out e6 and there's nothing wrong with e6
11 just prefers to keep his options open
he goes bishop to f4
and now knight's the d4 here rajab goes
for the c2 pawn and levin needs to
figure out what to do here does he
try and defend the pawn does he continue
aggressively with uh sorry
with e6 or does he uh try
something even greater he plays king f2
he gives up the pawn
uh to grab uh grab a lot of activity and
uh while you can capture the pawn it
does come with a
uh with a bit uh
well too much uh play from white for
example if you capture right away rotate
the c1
and now you could have some problems
here for example if knight to d4
you're just going to play knight to b5
and now there are
some issues here the c7 pawn is kind of
attacked twice there are already
threats like captures here uh then you
will be able to capture on c7
uh or just captures on c7 and then
captures here depending on what
black plays so here instead after king
of two rajabo first kicks away
uh one of 11's active pieces the knight
and g5
knight back to f3 and only now knight
captures on c2
so rajabo goes for it he gives 11
activity for the pawn
uh rook ate the c1 and now knight back
to b4
very cold-blooded by rajabov uh with a3
pushing the knight back and now
knights the c6 and here knights the d5
again there could be some problems here
on the c7 pawn if that e6 pawn is pushed
uh so
knight to e7 immediately trading off
that knight and
11 of course saves that knight back to
e3
uh knight back to c6 by the job of uh
now probably asking will 11 repeat
with knight to c4 then rajabo can go
back but 11 not interested in a
repetition he goes with
f6 and now again uh what do you do here
uh your g7 pawn is under attack and you
kind of don't want to capture
uh because you'll mess up your pawn
structure so here uh rajab
grabs control of the e6 square he plays
a bishop
d7 just controlling that square here uh
and
now b4 by 11. he really wants to open up
the c file to go after the black king
but now there's a bit of a problem here
as arajava pushes g5 and now the problem
is uh black is just doing black is just
doing well
and another thing is eleven has three
minutes on the clock whereas that java
has some
seven minutes on the clock uh so here we
have bishop
back to g3 uh rather uh
if you go for uh captures here right
away uh then uh it's not really all that
great instead of g5 for example if
captures then white gets the upper hand
with captures and g7 bishop captures and
captures here
and now this is a very good position for
white this is kind of what 11 was going
for and now especially if you capture
this pawn here
then e6 and the black will have a lot of
problems here so this is 11's plan
however rajab tricked him with g5
just uh chasing that bishop back bishop
to g3
and now bishop to e6 again grabbing hold
of that e6 square knight 38
is also gets the job done so bishop to
e6
and now rook to sorry not that rook to
d3 preparing to double rooks on the c
file king to b7 finally rajabo makes
room for the rook to enter the game
and rook d to c3 and now or only now
rook to d8 and you don't have to ever
worry about b
captures in c5 since the bishop guards
that pawn so
it's not a problem so here knight to f5
by 11
and now a5 putting pressure here on the
b4 pawn with b5 by 11
and now knight to a7 and now a4
so yeah this is pretty good for white as
that knight is stuck there on a7
not really having any good ways of
getting back into the game if you go
here then you
these scores are covered by white spawns
uh but there is one freeing move for
rajabov and that is c6
so you have to capture it as the b b5
pawn is attacked twice
so b captures on c6 knight captures on
c6 and now
the problem for 11 is even greater is
he's down to 20 seconds on the clock
whereas rajabo has some five minutes and
i always have to remind you since there
are new viewers
uh whenever in this particular
tournament when a player makes a move he
gets a 10 seconds increment so
if you continue making moves you're not
gonna run out of time
so king e2 11 starts improving the
position of his king and now
knight to b4 and here again 11 dropped
to some
10 seconds and you don't want to go
below that he played rook to d1
and now rajabov took some time i think
he took some minute and a half maybe
even two minutes to decide what to do
here
and he decided that a rook trade is
definitely in his favor
so rook captures on the one king
captures and now
knight to d5 attacking that rook and
also ideas like bishop d7 going after
the a4 pawn
are possible here since uh rajab has a
three to one advantage here
on the queen side and that's a lot if
that pawn falls then it's
it's immediately game over so here
rook to a3 guarding the pawn up front
and now
c4 pushing the pass pawn and opening up
an attack towards the rook here
and now finally this bishop was such a
problem for a job of the entire game
he's been stuck there blocking the rook
not having a good square
now the diagonal opens up and now the
bishop can be developed so here
knight the d6 with check uh forces uh
kind of forces a trait here we have
bishop captures e captures and now
uh the pawn is protected here but just
rook to d8
uh also uh if you go knight captures an
f6 then this just
uh ruins your game so you have to watch
out for stuff like that so after he
captures on d6 with rook to d8
and now bishop to e5 guarding both of
the pawns here so rajabo needs to now
figure out how to
how to try and convert his extra pawn
into a wind he goes knight to b4
uh we have bishop back to g3
and now comes knight to d3 so that's an
excellent outpost for the knight and of
course
white needs to do something about it we
have knights to d4
going after the bishop here and bishop
back to d7 the bishop nicely controls uh
all of the squares the knight can jump
to from d7
and king to d2 now uh rook to e8
preparing to
bring the rook over to the uh to the e
file
and now knight knights the c2
we have knight to c5 sorry that's the
king
and now rook to e3 just going after that
trade but nothing
really works here for 11 as uh that a4
pawn is just gonna fall there's no way
to add more defenders here
and now not even trading rooks right
away but rather knights to e4
with check and now uh the bishop will
fall so you you don't even have to trade
rooks king to c1 and now
knight captures and g3 you cannot trade
rooks because you have to
win back the piece so rook captures on
g3 and now
rook to e6 and now without that dark
square bishop these pawns are just uh
you know the easy easy food so here rook
to c3
11 also will try and grab some pawns
rook captures on f6 with rook captures
on c4
and rook captures on d6 king to b2
and here uh job we've just played rook
to d3 and he was now
in this position on 48 that uh eleven
are in and resign the game
and uh by winning game four uh of their
first match rajab wins the first match
so eleven will get his chance uh
uh tomorrow to equalize and then maybe
take the match into tie breaks
uh but we'll see what happens there and
here you're just uh down two pawns
there's no way to do anything here
you're gonna lose this pawn as well
and that's just uh such a big advantage
that it would be pointless to even
continue playing this for 11.
like maybe if rajava was extremely low
on time but i don't think that he'd do
it even then because you do get a 10
seconds increment
and there there's really no point in
even trying here
uh so a tough uh tough match for lebanon
on the first day but like i said he was
he was a little bit better in all three
of the first games
and then rajava was able to uh to to get
a draw but
then in this one he just pushed a little
bit too hard and a job of punished him
so
uh a job of uh i mean uh like i said uh
he didn't lose a single game to do both
uh then he
uh won the last four games he played
against dubo and now uh he didn't lose a
single game to eleven here
uh only uh in the one the the last game
so
uh it seems at a job of the the further
he goes into the tournament
he's more and more unbeatable but we'll
see what happens tomorrow uh
anything can still happen so uh sorry a
bit of a longer longer outro than usual
i hope you enjoyed that
and i would like to thank guillermo
rosas max mallor
uh ellen callahan yama camiar and
william fuller for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the finals
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so uh thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day